can we talk a little bit about the drake
equation
so another framework from which to have
this kind of discussion about
uh possible civilizations out there so
let me ask
within the context of the drake equation
or maybe bigger how many
alien civilizations do you think are out
there well it's hard to tell because the
drake equation is again quantifying our
ignorance it's just
a set of factors the only one
that we know are actually two that we
know quite well is
the rate of star formation in the milky
way galaxy which we
measured by now and the
frequency of planets like the earth
around stars yes
and at the right distance to have life
but
other than that there are lots of
implicit
assumptions about all the other factors
that will enable us to detect a signal
now i should say the drake equation has
a very limited validity just for
signals from civilizations that are
transmitting at the time that you're
observing them
you